[Musique]
ici à mon juste à côté de tours sylvie
bartolotti et toute son équipe de
l'association génération dance est bien
dans sa wii d'incidents justement y
danse tout le temps et avec tout le
monde y compris avec les personnes en
situation de handicap l'association a eu
l'idée d'organiser un spectacle au
profit des personnes en fauteuil roulant
depuis cette rencontre s'est transformé
en une véritable collaboration à leur
génération dance j'arrive et j'arrive en
dansant terrain samba
salsa
c'est le parcours
ça
[Musique]
la cgt millions avec plaisir travaux
communiste et hop et est ce que ça te
dirait une petite barre classique
maintenant au québec c'est parti d'un
passif alors je venais ou moi c'est ici
m'a fait mettre la mifi je suis désolé
il met toujours la plus sexy en premier
le hula on dit danse ça a commencé comme
ans quand génération dance a démarré il
faut absolument des cours spécifiques
pour eux parce que c'était difficile de
venir dans les cours habituels écoutez
moi je vais danser le tout le monde j'ai
fait du hip hop là c'est parti pour la
danse classique et après je vais me sied
aussi à la résidence un demi plié comme
je te reste bien
voilà tranquille qui baissent un peu tes
épaules et tu fais un grand pied tu
descends jusqu'en bas
petite visite et
voilà et tu montes sur 10 mais pointe
équilibrage la barre
super
[Musique]
mais bravo teboul très très mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo angeline vraiment c'est touchant
on est toujours pris par l'émotion
comment tu fais toi pour gérer l'émotion
comme ça au quotidien quand tu
travailles avec les personnes à handicap
comme ça avec un handicap sans handicap
on a tous nos casseroles nos talents et
donc bah voilà faut prendre les gens
comme ses seules causes humain si
seulement s'ils sont intégrés au
quotidien commun comme des danseurs bas
bien sûr tout simplement est ce que ce
sont des menteurs parce que ce sont des
danseurs mer et l'eau pas de danger que
j'ai vu des gamins les
ij excellent sur la gauche donc tu
tourne autour elle te tourner tout ça me
tombe tout
voilà après tu fasses derrière elle je
passe derrière comme ça on va là ouais
je prends ses bras le temps lui tombera
droit voilà voilà qui est soutien commun
comme un partenaire dans la
même chose à gauche voilà et après vous
vous regrouper tous les deux et cambrai
en arrière
[Musique]
oui
c'est sa génération dance c'est très
simple en fait c'est juste que eh bien
tout le monde en soit tout le monde dans
ce salon tout le monde danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]